la verdad que los cambios están por
verse pero lo que podemos advertir por
ahora es de alguna forma el incremento
de una gobernanza de tipo autoritaria me
explico
el proyecto de la nueva constitución que
se está votando el día de hoy
prácticamente va a acabar el incipiente
sistema semipresidencial que tenía túnez
hasta el momento recordemos que se
estableció alguna manera en todo el
proceso de transición desde el 2011 al
2014 y va a dar lugar a un sistema
totalmente presidencialista donde se
concentran todos los poderes públicos en
la figura del presidente es decir la
figura del primer ministro va a
desaparecer
o del del parlamento como un contrapeso
a la figura presidencial pues va también
a perder mucho de su influencia y sobre
todo la tradición del poder público algo
tan común en otros sectores del mundo en
este escenario va a ser seriamente
menguada y el mayor problema de este
referéndum y de la constitución
propuesta es que caixa y planea gobernar
por decreto presidencial una herramienta
que es una excepción pero ahora va a ser
la regla general